SIMON HOROBIN: So
this book looks
at where English has come
from, and how it's used today,
and considers what it might
look like in the future.
Users of English
get very anxious
about the state
of their language.
Since the 15th century,
in fact, people
have feared that
English is in decline.
And in an effort to halt
that downward spiral,
people turn to the
authorities that they
hold dear to consider how
to maintain and preserve
these standards.
But one of the questions
I raised in this book
is, where does the
authority lie when
it comes to determining the
rights and wrongs of language
use?
And since we all understand
that language does change over
time-- after all, Shakespeare's
language is very different
to ours--
we might wonder, why are
we so reluctant to let
it change today?
Now, getting back
to that question
about where the authority
lies in determining
rights and wrongs,
the obvious place,
I suppose, to turn in such
cases is a dictionary,
the ultimate authority
when it comes
to pronouncements over meaning.
But it's not always
quite that simple.
And to demonstrate
this, I thought
I'd take a recent, very
public disagreement
over the correct meaning of
a particular English word.
And this concerns
the word fulsome,
which you might remember
it was used recently
by Priti Patel, the former
international development
secretary, in her
resignation letter
to Theresa May, where
she says at the bottom
there, "I offer a
fulsome apology to you
and to the government
for what has happened
and offer my resignation."
The editor of "The Times
Literary Supplement,"
Stig Abell, responded to the
news of this announcement
by claiming that Priti
Patel had got it wrong.
And that what she should have
said was "a full apology."
And he claimed "fulsome"
means insincere.
She's actually said the opposite
of what she meant to say.
Now, predictably, of
course, this controversy
was taken up by
"Radio 4," and there
was a debate on
the "World at One"
over the correct meaning
of the word "fulsome."
It's a nice example,
I think, of the way
in which, for users of English,
the niceties of correct usage
are often more newsworthy
than the actual news itself.
So we had a debate between
Stig Abell and reformed pedant
and "Times"
columnist Oliver Kamm
about the correct
meaning of this word.
But what is the answer
then to this vexed debate
over the correct
meaning of fulsome?
Who got it right?
Where do we turn?
Well, if we look in the
Oxford English Dictionary,
we might think of as
the ultimate authority--
I know I'm slightly
biased, but it's one place
people would turn--
then we can see that the
earliest uses of the word
"fulsome," which date
back to the 14th century,
mean-full, abundant,
or plentiful.
It's kind of what we'd expect
from the word "fulsome."
It sort of sounds like
it's going to mean that.
So if we consider that the
correct meaning of the word
is the earliest one, then
Priti Patel's fulsome apology
is simply one that is very full.
But if we were to take the
view that the correct meaning
of a word is the oldest
meaning of the word,
then that is problematic for
a number of different reasons.
So for instance, the word silly
originally meant innocent.
Nice originally meant foolish.
Tall originally meant handsome.
If we went around trying
to insist on the earliest
historical meanings
of these words,
we'd be in all
kinds of confusion.
So what happened to the
word fulsome, subsequently?
Well, if we look up
the latest developments
of the word in the OED, we can
see that, by the 17th century,
it had indeed developed
some different usages.
And so for OED sense five
of language or behavior,
sense 5A is offensive
or objectionable,
owing to excess or
lack of moderation--
excessively effusive,
complimentary, too lavish,
overdone.
So this is obviously the
sense that Stig Abell
was taking it in.
It's perhaps this
development, I suspect,
that's perhaps typical of
the British uncomfortableness
with sincerity--
anyone being complimentary
simply being gushy
and overdoing it.
By the early 20th century,
however, the word fulsome
began to be used in a
positive sense once again,
perhaps owing to the
ambiguity in expressions
like "fulsome
praise," in which it's
difficult to
understand or determine
whether it's supposed to be
negative, positive, or neutral.
And so OED sense
5B is unrestrained,
exuberant, effusive,
lavish, wholehearted.
So the Oxford English
Dictionary allows
us to trace this historical
overview of the world
and chart the changing
meanings of it over time,
but it doesn't
actually tell us what's
the correct meaning today.
And in fact, what we can
see from the evidence
is that both senses 5A and
5B are still current today.
So it seems, in fact, that
there's real potential
for ambiguity here-- a word
that can be used to mean--
so when we talk about
fulsome praise, for instance,
we might mean it to mean
abundant and heartfelt
or perhaps overdone
and insincere.
That might seem
unhelpfully confusing,
calling out for some authority
figure to come and legislate
as to which the correct
meaning of the word is.
You know, the OED,
perhaps, should tell us,
use it this way, not that way.
But in fact, that's not
really the way language works.
It's the hands of
the users rather than
of the lexicographers.
And after all, many words have
a variety of different meanings,
perhaps not quite as extreme
as these contradictory uses
of the word "fulsome."
But a parallel
case perhaps might
be the recent developments
in the use of the word
"literally," which of
course, etymologically,
if you're one of those
literally pedants, means--
comes from Latin
littera, "letter."
So it means "to the letter,"
or "precisely," or "exactly."
But now, of course,
it's widely used
to mean precisely the opposite--
metaphorically speaking.
And for some people,
of course, that's
a travesty of the
correct meaning,
leading to all kinds of
potential for confusion.
But is it really confusing?
How many times when
you hear somebody
say, I'm literally
dying for a coffee,
do you actually
phone an ambulance?
We can work it out
from the context.
And of course, the
phrases "fulsome apology"
and "fulsome praise" are
potentially ambiguous,
as we've seen.
But we don't usually have to
interpret them in a vacuum.
Understanding of the
word, as with all words,
is guided by context.
In the case we've
been looking at,
it's a resignation letter
in which she expresses
clear regret for her actions.
It's, of course, possible
that the use of "fulsome"
here was some kind
of covert attempt
to distance herself
from the apology.
It seems unlikely.
What's clear, I think, is that
Ms. Patel didn't use the word
incorrectly, rather Stig Abell
chose to deliberately misread
a potentially ambiguous usage.
And interestingly, in the "Radio
4" discussion on the "World
at One," Stig Abell began
by immediately conceding
that he realized now
that the sense of full
was perfectly acceptable--
made me wonder why he didn't
look it up in the dictionary
before he fired off the tweet.
But nevertheless, at
least by this stage,
he'd realized he was wrong.
He didn't, though, however,
offer Ms. Patel an apology,
fulsome or otherwise.
He simply went on to
accuse her of, what
is for English speakers I
suspect, an even worse sin--
that of using a longer
word to sound more clever.
So now, she's being
accused of saying "fulsome"
because it sounds better and
more intelligent than "full."
This is what HW Fowler,
in his classic usage guide
"Modern English Usage"
of 1926, memorably
encapsulated in the maxim,
the love of the long word,
came up with this
maxim-- the better
the writer, the
shorter his words.
And this is an example of
many of these very nice, sort
of easily quotable
and memorable ideas
which, of course, are
useful in some cases
but not in all cases.
And it's certainly not the
case that all long words
are an attempt to deliberately
obfuscate or show off.
Sometimes, they're
just the right word.
And Stig Abell,
of course, didn't
explain how he knew
that this was an attempt
to sound intelligent, and
instead, the discussion
descended rather
predictably and depressingly
into a discussion of
rather predictable,
well-worn favorites, such as
the correct meaning of decimate,
disinterested, and so.
What this example
shows, I think,
is that questions
of correct usage
are not always as easily
resolved as we might hope.
Language is more
complicated than that.
Turning to a dictionary
can shed light
on the ways in which a word
like "fulsome" is used,
but it doesn't
necessarily provide us
with clear right
and wrong judgments.
And the reason for
that is that that's not
what lexicographers do when
they compile dictionaries.
They're simply
recording how words
are used based upon
analysis of large quantities
of actual data-- actual usage.
So dictionaries then
are descriptive rather
than prescriptive.
They describe the
language use rather
than telling us how to use it.
The authority of
traditional dictionaries
is under threat today
from online resources
like Urban Dictionary.
I don't know how many
people would instead--
in an example like this--
instead of the OED,
choose Urban Dictionary.
But of course, in such
cases, the authority
is being taken away from the
professional lexicographer
and placed in the
hands of the user.
So the users are given the
power to choose the words,
to define them,
and add quotations,
unlike a traditional
dictionary, which
sets out to report
the facts of usage
in an impartial, neutral way.
Online dictionaries-- the
partiality and bias of the user
is openly displayed, often
leading to rather contested
and contradictory entries.
So as an example
of that, I've got
two definitions that
are provided in Urban
Dictionary for man-flu.
See if you can work out
where the bias lies here.
It's not terribly complicated.
"The condition
shared by all males
where in a common illness,
usually mild cold,
is presented by the patient
as life-threatening.
Man flu is more painful
than childbirth.
This is irrefutable,
scientific fact."
Now, it's fairly obvious
where the bias lies here.
But in other cases, they
can be more complicated.
The opportunity
to redefine words
can have potentially dangerous
consequences, especially
in an era of post-truth
and fake news.
For instance, when Ivanka
Trump last year was recently
accused of being complicit
in her father's agenda,
she defended herself by
saying, "If being complicit
is wanting to be
a force for good
and to make a positive
impact, then I'm complicit."
Now, that might seem
reasonable enough,
but is that what
complicit actually means?
People turned to online
dictionaries to find out.
So for instance, dictionary.com
recorded an 11,000% spike
in searches for
the word complicit
following that interview.
And it led them to make it
their word of the year for 2017.
And of course, in the
dictionary, how it's defined
is "involved with others
in an activity that
is unlawful or morally wrong."
There's a subtle
distinction there.
So I've been suggesting
that lexicographers
don't see themselves as arbiters
of linguistic correctness
but authors of usage
guides very frequently do.
So I'm thinking of works
like Simon Heffer's "Strictly
English" or Neville
Gwynn's "Gwynn's Grammar,"
which set out to
willfully misrepresent
the complexities of
actual usage in order
to reduce them to simple
rights and wrongs.
So unlike lexicographers,
authors of usage guides
issue strongly
worded prescriptions
that are based on little more
than personal preference.
As an example, I've
got here Simon Heffer's
"Strictly English" definition
of the word "fulsome."
So he says, "We've all read
the phrase about someone
making a fulsome apology.
Those who write it usually
believe that the adjective
means full or plentiful.
It has not meant that since
the early 16th century.
And after 500 years
of obsoleteness,
we may legitimately consider
that use redundant."
Now, as we've just
seen, of course,
that's completely not the case.
In fact, since the
early 20th century,
that use has been widely in use.
So this is a complete
misrepresentation.
But it makes for a very
straightforward kind
of distinction-- it's wrong
to use it in that way.
And so it seems
to me unsurprising
that users of English in search
of guidance and certainty
turn to works like these--
the authoritative tone,
the clear-cut judgment
makes reassuring reading.
I suspect Stig Abell,
editor of the "TLS,"
has a copy on his
desk that he reached
for when Priti Patel
signed off that tweet.
But the problem is that
it's totally misrepresenting
this evidence, giving the
readers a misplaced confidence
in its claims.
What's perhaps even more
baffling about books
like this is that not even
the authors pay attention
to many of the rules that
they themselves lay down.
I've got a few examples of this
from Simon Heffer's "Strictly
English."
So for instance, here's what he
says about the word "mutual."
"Mutual does not mean 'shared,'
it means reciprocated.
Dickens would have
better called his book,
'Our Common Friend.'" But then
when he comes to write his own
work, "The Victorians," he says,
"He saw Ralph Waldo Emerson
during the Americans visit to
England in the winter of 1848,
and they spoke much of their
mutual friend Carlyle."
The next example
concerns the word
"involvement," where he says,
"The noun involvement is used
with equal lack of precision.
There's no need to write
that Smith's involvement
in the crime is disputed
when one should say
that his part was disputed."
And here he is, in
"The Victorians"
again, "When the South London
Working Man's college was
established in 1868,
Huxley accepted
the role of honorary principal
in which he served until 1880,
and where his involvement was
far from just ornamental."
I've got one more example.
I have tried to
restrain myself here.
You can see I quite
enjoy doing this.
I could have given
you loads more.
The next one is on enormity.
And here he says,
"An enormity is
something bad, a transgression,
not something big.
One should speak not of
the enormity of the task
but of its enormousness, even if
one is president of the United
States."
That might seem like a
slightly bizarre thing to say,
but this is in
reference to the way
that Barack Obama came under
fire from the usage police
after his presidential
acceptance speech in 2008,
where he said he was humbled by
the enormity of the task ahead.
And of course all the
headline writers said,
he's got it wrong.
He should have said
"enormousness."
So even he can get it wrong, but
of course, so can Simon Heffer.
"Moral Desperado," his biography
of Thomas Carlyle, where
he says, "Carlyle
was about to embark
on his first large-scale
literary project--
a life of Schiller,
was overwhelmed
by the enormity of the task."
Now, if even authors
of usage guides
don't follow the rules that
they themselves are advocating,
we might wonder why they're
so concerned that everyone
else should, and why
does anybody bother
paying any attention to them?
I suspect that
part of the answer
lies in society's
tacit acceptance
that there are rights and wrongs
in all aspects of language use
and a desire to be safe
from embarrassment.
So rather than question the
grounds for the prescription,
we turn to the usage
pundits, just as we once
turned to our
schoolteachers in search
of guidance and certitude.
Many of us, of course,
have fixed ideas
about proper language use.
And we use those often
to identify people
that we deem to be, in even in
Moore's helpful formulation,
NLOs--
people who are "not like one."
Even though the rules that
we're often using are ones
that don't necessarily show any
relationship to actual usage.
They've been passed down to us.
We've taken them on.
Although, I suspect few
of us go quite as far
as Brian Henderson, who gets
so incensed by people using
"comprised of"
that he's corrected
this supposed
misuse on Wikipedia
more than 47,000 times.
Although, many
people would no doubt
consider the thousands
of hours that he admits
to having spent on this
crusade to be something
of a waste of time,
he would no doubt
win the approval of
Bill Bryson, who,
in his dictionary of troublesome
words, says of "comprised of,"
"If you remember nothing
else from this book,
remember, at least,
that 'comprised of'
is always wrong."
Part of the attraction
then, I think, of statements
like these is that they
are black and white.
A usage is either
right or wrong.
And even better, like Brian
Henderson, once we know it,
we can go around
correcting everyone
else who doesn't know it.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, probably the
classic feature
of English usage that's really
liable to raise the blood
pressure of those concerned with
correctness is the apostrophe.
Yeah, I'm sensing already--
I can hear some grumbling in the
audience that already tells me
I'm on dodgy territory here.
[LAUGHTER]
The former chief editor of the
Oxford English Dictionary, John
Simpson, in his recent
memoir, "The Word Detective,"
says of the apostrophe, "The
English are temperamentally
obsessed with the presence
or absence of apostrophes.
It remains, for many people,
a divide between civilization
and chaos."
And indeed, in 2014,
when Cambridge Council
voted to abandon
apostrophes in street signs,
it prompted a rogue
grammar gorilla
to prowl the streets at night,
armed only with a black marker
pen.
You probably can't even tell--
it's done so beautifully.
But these are some black
marker penned-in apostrophes
in Scholars' Walk
and Pepys' Court.
And this led to
Cambridge Council
rapidly reversing the decision,
giving in to public pressure
and restoring the precious
apostrophe to the street
signs of Cambridge.
Although, it's never
really explained
why if its Scholars'
Walk and Pepys' Place,
it's "Fitzgerald's Place."
There's not complete
consistency there.
And of course, let's not even
go into whether it should be
Pepys' apostrophe or
Pepy's-- apostrophe S.
And in April 2017, the
media reported on the Banksy
of punctuation-- it's this
guy-- the self-styled grammar
vigilante who patrols the
streets of Bristol by night,
armed only with what he
calls his "apostrophizer--"
[LAUGHTER]
--which is basically
that long stick
with an apostrophe
on the end of it.
And he goes around climbing
up ladders in pitch dark
and putting in missing
apostrophes into street signs
and shop signs.
Now, for many people,
this punctuation crusader
is a hero--
bravely upholding standards in
a society that ceased to care.
But for others, he
represents the unsavory side
of linguistic pedantry,
reveling in social snobbery
and one-upmanship.
The apostrophe has long
been a polarizing issue
amongst otherwise
rational people.
George Bernard
Shaw, for instance,
who was a vocal critic
of English spelling
and left a fortune in
his will for somebody
to devise a whole new alphabet
to replace the Roman alphabet
with which English is written.
He insisted on dropping all
apostrophes and so wrote
"can't" and "he's"
without apostrophes--
like that because, he
said, there is no--
"not the faintest
reason for persisting
in the ugly and silly
trick of peppering pages
with these uncouth bacilli."
Lewis Carroll, on
the other hand,
was a big fan of
apostrophes and insisted
that the only correct spelling
of shan't and can't was,
as you see here, with additional
apostrophes to indicate
the proper contractions.
Now, of course, many today
will happily omit apostrophes
in emails and tweets, but others
still insist on including it.
So for instance, the
self-appointed monitor
of Twitter posts, your or
you're simply retweets messages
where the two homophones
have been confused
and then adds "wrong" at
the beginning of them.
[LAUGHTER]
When it comes to the serious
business of apostrophes,
even the laid-back
lexicographers
of the Oxford English
Dictionary can lose their cool.
So for instance, going back
to John Simpson's "Word
Detective," he describes
that when the Oxford English
Dictionary moved its
offices in Oxford
to a grand Georgian building on
St. Giles', considerable effort
was invested in researching
whether the headed notepaper
should read St.
Giles' apostrophe
or with no apostrophe.
For all the time spent
consulting local records,
newspapers, etymologists in
order to determine the correct
form was indeed St.
Giles' with an apostrophe.
That's to show you that St.
Giles' Cafe knew it all along
and could have told
them for nothing.
The lexicographers'
judgments, though,
have had little effect
on other businesses
on the streets and road signs--
so St. Giles-- without one.
Missing apostrophes like these
are met with dismay and anger
by those concerned about
linguistic standards who
fear that such changes are
undermining our ability
to communicate.
But is the apostrophe
really so crucial
to the well-being
of our society?
And would consigning it to
the dustbin really threaten
the future of our language
as a means of communication?
It's seldom recognized that
the apostrophe is, of course,
just a feature of
the written language
with no spoken language
correspondence.
So I'm talking to you now
using lots of contractions, not
apostrophes, and somehow
you're still understanding me.
If we can do that
in speech, we might
wonder whether we could
do without it in writing.
And in fact, the apostrophe
in the history of English
is a relatively
recent innovation.
It was first introduced
into English printed books
in the 16th century to indicate
an elision or a contraction,
as it does, of course, still
today in "she'll," and "can't,"
and "it's" for "it is."
And then, it was extended
in the 17th century
to indicate possession
in singular nouns--
like here-- the boy's,
apostrophe S, book,
where the understanding
was that here, something
had been contracted or omitted.
In this case, they thought
it was the third person
possessive pronoun "his."
The boy-- "his book"
had been abbreviated
to "the boy's book."
In fact, that's
completely wrong.
The S ending here is
simply an inflectional
ending-- a generative ending.
It goes back to an
earlier form of English
where it was much more heavily
used inflectional endings.
But it sort of
made sense to them
because it was a contraction
to extend it in this way.
And then, subsequently
in the 18th century,
further confusion was introduced
when the apostrophe was
used for plural possessives,
putting it after to the S,
where of course, nothing's
been omitted at all.
And so as a consequence,
the apostrophe
has taken on two slightly
different and contradictory
roles to signal both elision
and now also possession.
And of course it's that
contradiction that causes much
of today's confusion, most
notoriously, of course,
in the distinction
between its and it's--
I-T- apostrophe S and I-T-S.
Now, for Lynne Truss, the author
of "Eats, Shoots, and Leaves--
the Zero Tolerance Guide
to English Punctuation,"
the rules of its and it's
are extremely simple.
And so the punishment
for breaking it
should be suitably brutal.
And she says getting
your itses mixed up
is the greatest solecism
in the world punctuation.
"No matter that you have a PhD
and read all of Henry James
twice, if you persist in writing
'good food at it's best,' you
deserve to be
struck by lightning,
hacked up on the spot, and
buried in an unmarked grave."
But since the apostrophe
can signal possession,
it is reasonable to assume that
the neuter possessive pronoun
"its" should also
have an apostrophe.
And in fact, there's some
historical precedent here, too.
Because the "its"
pronoun was first
introduced in English
in the 17th century
to replace the
earlier pronoun "his,"
which, rather
unhelpfully, overlapped
with the masculine possessive
pronoun, also "his."
And because it was formed by
taking the subject pronoun "it"
and adding the S
genitive singular ending,
the new pronoun was
indeed initially written
I-T- apostrophe S
for the possessive,
just as it is here in the
first folio of Shakespeare
in "The Tempest."
Insecurity about where to
place the apostrophe increasing
leads to its omission.
So we frequently find examples
where it's been left out,
and then of course also
contexts in which it's
been added in unnecessarily.
And the most common
of these, of course,
is what's known as the
greengrocer's apostrophe, where
it's added before a plural S--
so-called the
greengrocer's apostrophe
because it's,
apparently, most commonly
used by greengrocers
advertising apples, and oranges,
and so on with
apostrophe S. There's
some historical justification
for this, however, also.
So for instance,
here you can see
when foreign words were
borrowed into English
in the 18th century
ending in vowels,
it was very common to write
apostrophe S for the plural,
as you can see in
that example there--
"Handel's Opera's."
So these have some
historical justification
and aren't necessarily just
straightforwardly errors.
And of course, we still use the
apostrophe S when we're writing
plurals of things like P's
and Q's and do's and don'ts.
But despite this, Lynne
Truss's zero-tolerance message
struck a chord with
a huge audience--
this is a massive bestseller,
"Easts, Shoots, and
Leaves," an audience who
saw her as the champion
of good English.
The success of "Eats,
Shoots, and Leaves"
helps to highlight a
more cynical reason
for the constant stream
of books peddling
extreme prescriptivism,
and that is that it sells.
The huge demand for
books of this kind
can be traced back
to the beginnings
of the prescriptive tradition
in the 18th century.
So up until that
point, it was just
a trickle of handbooks about
English grammar, spelling,
and punctuation.
But after the 18th century,
that was hugely increased.
And in the 19th century,
there was a publication
of many of these kinds of
prescriptive usage guides
and grammars, including
ones with alluring titles
like these, "Poor letter H--
Its Use and Abuse Addressed
to its Little Vowels."
This is all about H dropping,
if you're aware of that concept.
You know, where you say
"ow" instead of "how,"
"and" instead of "hand."
Again, a hugely sort
of divisive feature
of English pronunciation,
which we can trace back
to the 18th century,
where dropping your H's
is seen as being slovenly--
you don't care very much.
You can't be bothered.
You're lazy.
You know, it's very
closely related
in the 19th century, the idea
of poor English and poor social
skills, being vulgar, and so on.
And this one-- "Don't--
A Manual of Mistakes
and Improprieties More
or Less Prevalent in
Conduct and Speech."
There's a close association
here between good English
and good breeding
and the assumption
that making mistakes shows that
you're vulgar and slovenly.
To give you a sort of
flavor of "Don't," I've
included a few examples here.
You quite quickly pick
up the style of the book.
It makes rather sort
of slow reading.
"Don't speak ungrammatically.
Study books of grammar and the
writings of the best authors.
Don't pronounce incorrectly.
Listen to the conversation
of cultivated people.
And if in doubt, consult
the dictionaries.
Don't notice in others
a slip in grammar
or a mispronunciation in a way
to cause blush or to offend.
If you refer to
anything of the kind,
do it courteously and not in
the hearing of other persons."
That's one that I
think we probably still
could learn a bit from.
Where electronic
usage today is often
seen as a forum in which
standards of grammar, spelling,
and punctuation are relaxed,
and where nonstandard usage
is tolerated or even encouraged,
sites like Twitter, Facebook,
and Instagram are also used
as a means for sticklers
to find a wider audience for
the linguistic blunders they
find around them.
So for instance, Twitter
accounts like this one--
Grammar Nazi.
How many of you
follow Grammar Nazi?
Incidentally,
Grammar Nazi must be
one of the few areas
left in society where
it's socially acceptable
to self-identify as a Nazi.
Many people use that
in their Twitter bios.
But these kinds of
sites, of course,
seldom take account of the
fact that the perpetrators
of the errors that
they are shaming
are often non-native speakers
of English or people with access
to fewer educational
standards and opportunities
than themselves.
Donald Trump's
notorious misspellings,
as are sort of heralded
here-- so these
are examples like-- my next
slide has a few of these.
You probably see many more--
"payed," "tapp," "honered,"
"dummer," "unpresidented--"
that's quite a nice one--
[LAUGHTER]
--hearby-- sort of Freudian.
Now, these, of course,
might seem like fair game.
But here, we run
the risk, I think,
of falling into the same trap
as the "Radio 4" discussion
over the correct
meaning of fulsome.
Does it matter that the most
powerful man in the world
can't spell or can't be
bothered to use a dictionary?
Well, maybe, but
surely not as much
as his attitude to
the Middle East,
or North Korea, or global
warming, or human rights,
and so on.
Our love for correcting others
is epitomized in the success
of T-shirts like this one--
"I'm silently correcting
your grammar."
Now, of course,
since many people--
speakers of English
use regional dialects,
this is often simply
a way of engaging
in regional and social snobbery.
While the term
"dialect" is popularly
employed to refer to
a nonstandard or even
substandard form of the
language, for linguists,
the term is actually neutral.
So standard English
is simply just one
of the dialects of
English, albeit one
that's been accorded greater
social status, whereas we tend
to think very often
as standard English
being above all the other
dialects of English.
It's that recognition that all
dialects are linguistically
important that prompted an
American linguist to produce
a rival T-shirt.
And this says, "Not judging your
grammar, just analysing it."
But this has provoked unease,
even amongst its supporters.
So one US tweeter found herself
in support of the sentiment
but unable to wear
the T-shirt because it
uses the British English
spelling of analyzing--
that's with the S rather than a
Z. You see how difficult it is?
Comments like these,
I think, remind us
that however tolerant
we might like
to think we are about
linguistic variation,
we all have our own pet peeves
and linguistic bugbears.
So even professional linguists
could be guilty of this.
So Deborah Cameron, the
author of an important study
of linguistic prescriptivism
called "Verbal Hygiene,"
says that when--
while she has learned to
overcome knee-jerk judgments
that are inappropriate
in her field,
she still finds
herself sensitive
to particular solecisms.
"I can choose to suppress the
irritation I feel when I see,
for example, a sign
that reads potatoe's"--
there's the greengrocer's
apostrophe again--
"I cannot choose
not to feel it."
See how sort of ingrained
these ideas are?
And you can see
from the next slide
not everyone feels
the same restraint.
Are you that person that always
has that marker pen on you
just in case?
Part of the reason
for our unwillingness
to accept the changing meanings
of words like "fulsome"
and the demise of
the apostrophe is
that we've taken the trouble
to learn the rules surrounding
their use and so have
considerable investment
in ensuring that other people
are obliged to observe them.
And that applies also
to the complexities
of English spelling.
So we might tacitly acknowledge,
with its silent letters
and erratic relationship
to pronunciation,
the English spelling
isn't a terribly
efficient and effective way of
conveying the English language.
But because we have
spent and invested
so much time in learning it, we
feel rather judgmental of those
who make spelling mistakes.
And here, I'm going to give
you a quick spelling test, OK?
And how do you spell
the word supersede?
I'll give you a moment to
think about that-- supersede--
S-U-P-E-R-- and then I want to
know whether you'd say S-E-D-E
or C-E-D-E?
[MIXED CROWD RESPONSE]
So let's say hands
up for the C. OK.
Most people.
Hands up for the S?
OK, it's actually S.
Interesting, isn't it?
Interesting.
The reason for this is that
it comes back to etymology.
And the word "supersede"
goes back to the Latin,
supersedere--
to sit on top of, literally--
superseding something--
sits on top of it.
Whereas those of you
who thought it was a C
probably were thinking of
words like recede, intercede,
and precede, which actually have
a different Latin etymology.
They come from the
verb cedere, to go.
Now, the reason I
used this example
is because so many people
get it wrong, in fact.
If you got it wrong, you were
in the majority in this room,
but also in all the times
I've asked this question.
And what it makes me
wonder is, does that
mean that many people don't
know how to spell and need
to go back to school and learn?
Or does it mean that
the spelling of the word
"supersede" is
actually changing?
More people are spelling it
with a C rather than an S.
Now, you might
also argue that it
would be better
if we did spell it
that way because it fits
more with recede, intercede,
and precede.
It's a more logical
spelling of the language.
Do we need to preserve those
etymological distinctions,
which, after all, don't
really mean very much
for modern uses of English?
I know, from
personal experience,
people are very
hostile to the idea
that spelling should be
allowed to change over time.
It's probably the
area of the language
that people feel most invested
in the ideas of correctness.
There's only one correct
way to spell a word.
But in fact, evidence
that this word might
be changing its meaning--
in the Merriam-Webster
Dictionary,
"supercede" with a C is
a variant of "supersede."
Seems as if it's
becoming more acceptable.
For those of you who did
get it right and think,
that's just wrong, you'll be
glad to see that the Oxford
Dictionary online says it's
generally regarded as an error.
Although, notice, generally
regarded as an error--
is that sort of opening
the door to the possibility
that that might change in time?
Well, as I said, people are
very hostile to this idea.
I suggested this when I did a
test of the audience at the Hay
Festival a few years
ago on this exact word,
and then suggested that
perhaps this word was
changing its spelling.
I found myself the next
day front page news
all over the world bizarrely.
Here's a particular headline
I enjoyed in Oxford--
accused of single-handedly
lowering literacy expectations
amongst primary school children
all over the country and so on.
We might wonder whether the
increasing development of
and adoption of
emojis, though, which
allow speakers to communicate
without the need for language,
means that we'll no
longer need to learn
to spell and cease to
communicate in English at all.
I put the winky face emoji there
to tell you I'm just joking.
Don't worry.
But am I, actually?
Because there are, after all,
a billion users of English
in the world today, but
that number is positively
dwarfed by the number of
people who have a smartphone
and who use emojis.
And in fact, emoji use
has expanded to the extent
now that it's common
for entire messages
to be conveyed
using these symbols,
enabling them to be understood
by speakers of any language.
So here's an example from Andy
Murray's wedding day tweet,
where he describes what happened
to him on his wedding day
using emojis.
Now, it's relatively easy
to decode this message,
given the typical
wedding day involves
a number of conventional,
formulaic activities.
It's harder when the message
is written entirely in emoji
and completely decontextualized.
And to give you an
example of that,
here are two opening sentences
from famous novels written
in emoji.
Any ideas what the first one is?
AUDIENCE: Best of times.
SIMON HOROBIN: Best of
times, the worst of times.
Yeah, loses a little bit
in translation, doesn't it?
But I'll go down
to the second one.
AUDIENCE: "Pride and Prejudice."
SIMON HOROBIN: "Pride
and Prejudice."
Yeah, exactly.
That's right.
There's a truth
universally acknowledged
that a man in possession
of a good fortune
must be in need of a wife.
But where the use of emoji has
grown out of a radical move
to shake off the constraints
of written language,
users remain restricted by
the numbers and types of emoji
available.
And release of new
emoji, of course,
subject to the approval
of the Unicode Consortium,
which is a kind of linguistic
Academy, I suppose.
And decisions like these are
typically rather contentious,
given the lack of representation
of certain ethnic groups,
their cultures, and religions.
And it only recently has
been possible to choose
from a range of skin tones
and the official uses--
a kind of dictionary
of etymology
set out in the
emoji PDF database.
While recent updates
have enabled greater
cultural diversity, the
representation of foods,
and clothes, and
places of worship
still remain highly westernized.
However representative
emoji become,
it's not possible to legislate
for the cultural sensitivity
of the user, either.
So for instance, the
pine decoration emoji,
which represents
kadomatsu, placed
at the front of Japanese
homes at New Year
to welcome the spirits in the
hope of a plentiful harvest,
is regularly used in the
West as an offensive gesture.
There's not much you
can do about that.
The creativity with which
users repurpose emojis
is further apparent from
the surprising success
of the aubergine
or eggplant emoji
amongst sexting teenagers, which
prompted Instagram to ban it
from their searching facility.
And the success of the
suggestive connotations
of the aubergine
emoji has even led
to the establishment
of eggplantmale.com,
a company that allows you
to send a personalized
message on an aubergine
anywhere in the world.
But I don't think there's
any danger of emoji replacing
English as the global language.
It would need a vastly
increased number of characters.
Most significantly, it
lacks the grammatical rules
that are necessary for
the formation of more
complex constructions.
And that claim might
seem to be undermined
by the appearance, recently,
of the entirety of Herman
Melville's novel
"Moby Dick" in emoji--
"Emogi Dick," as it's known.
The entire novel has been
translated for you into emoji.
And you might think,
well, in that case,
if you can do "Moby
Dick," then surely we
can do basic conversation.
But it seems to me that a glance
at the resulting translation
highlights the
limitations of the format.
So for instance, you can
see here the famous opening
sentence, "Call me
Ishmael" represented
by a telephone, a man with
a mustache, a boat, a whale,
and an OK sign.
Doesn't quite do it for me.
So in conclusion, then, the
future of the English language
seems assured, but
it's likely to be
a future of multiple Englishes,
as new technologies emerge
and as new users continue
to adopt it and adapt
it to suit a wide
range of functions
across the English
speaking globe.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you, Simon.
We've got time for
a few questions.
So if you put your hand up, I'll
try to get to you with the mic.
AUDIENCE: Hey, so we've got
all the options with operating
systems and in our
phones and whatnot
to add misspelled
words to dictionary
so that it won't
constantly remind us
that we're misspelling things.
Do you get any data
from any of that
to see trends of what's
changing in what you do?
SIMON HOROBIN: Oxford
Dictionary collects all of that,
but they collect it from the
perspective of what people
type into the online
dictionary searching capacity--
so the number of times that
people search for a word
and misspell it.
So for instance, they've
put data on how many times
people are entering "supersede"
with the supposed incorrect
spelling.
So that kind of data
I've seen, but not
precisely what you are asking.
But that's very interesting.
That's the sort of
thing-- you're right.
That would be interesting
to capture more of
and see the total.
Because of course,
a lot of what--
the reason why people think
of spelling as being so fixed
is that what we're
mostly used to seeing
and what dictionaries are used
to seeing is published texts,
which has rather
artificially gone
through a whole process of
auto correcting, proofreading,
copyediting, and so on,
where people are spending
laborious amounts of time trying
to ensure that the spelling is
all correct.
And where, of course,
when people are actually
writing by hand or typing
things in without checking it,
very often, of course,
we get things wrong.
AUDIENCE: How many
of these challenges
are unique to English, and how
many apply to all languages?
SIMON HOROBIN:
Interesting question.
I mean, all languages change.
All languages that are
spoken and used are changed.
Of course, the
ones that don't are
sort of fixed, dead languages
like Latin, for instance.
So all languages are
changing that are being used.
But of course, English,
what it has particularly is
the way that English
is growing today,
in terms of new speakers,
are people using it
as a second language.
I mean, it's not
unique to English
because that's true
of, say, Spanish,
too, but the large percentage
of people that are requiring it
as second language--
and therefore it's
being sort of learned
in different ways.
And it is then
coming into contact
with a much wider range of
different languages spoken
by different people.
That's causing all kinds of
new forms of English to emerge.
So for instance,
English in South Asia,
where it's a big growth area--
we've got things like
Singlish, where it's English,
but it's spoken
by people who also
speak Mandarin, who
also use a variety
of different languages--
Malay and so on-- that
are borrowing words
from those other
language they speak.
And so what we're seeing is
new forms of English emerging.
Is that a form of English,
or is it a form of Singlish,
or is it something
else in between?
Sometimes they're
called interlanguages.
And so I think that's sort of
unique to English in the sense
that it's such a
global language.
AUDIENCE: You
touched a little bit
on how you might
correct somebody
if you hear something wrong.
If I was to say to you, can
I lend that pen off you?
What would you say, and
how would you handle it?
SIMON HOROBIN: Yeah,
that's an interesting one.
So again, that, to me,
is a dialect usage.
So it's quite common in
some dialects of English
to use the word
"lend" to mean borrow.
There are other languages
where the same word-- sorry?
AUDIENCE: I agree.
Yeah, in Wales that's
certainly fine.
SIMON HOROBIN: Yeah, so I
would take the perspective
that that's a dialect usage.
And therefore,
it's wrong in terms
of if I take the standard
English as the correct form
of the language.
But if you spoke it, you
are speaking a dialect,
and there's no
compulsion on people
to speak standard English.
Often that is what
people are saying--
is that what you're
saying is wrong
because it's not standard.
But actually, we're
only really compelled
to write standard English.
If you wrote that, then that
might be more problematic.
So if a student put that in
an essay to me for instance,
I would have to correct
it on the grounds
that I'm trying to
make sure that they're
writing in standard English.
But if they said
it to me, then I'd
be inclined to just let it go,
because it's just their dialect
form.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I'll let my mother know.
SIMON HOROBIN: Right.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I could perhaps ask--
from the Polish language,
sometimes the word
is written in one
way, and it's supposed
to be read in that
way, but people
start using a letter that
actually doesn't exist
or a sound that
actually doesn't exist.
Why do people do this?
I can give an example.
We have a word [NON-ENGLISH],,
which means to turn something
on.
And people say, [NON-ENGLISH]
and such letter doesn't exist.
How does it happen?
Can you stop this?
[LAUGHTER]
SIMON HOROBIN: I'm not sure
whether that's something
that's particular to Polish.
But I mean, changes
in pronunciation
happen all the time.
They're often driven
by people assuming
that what you're doing when
you're pronouncing a word
is you are following the
spelling quite closely.
And so the history of
English quite often
is the emergence of
spelling pronunciations,
partly because,
particularly in English,
literacy is seen as
such an important thing.
So that's why H dropping, for
instance, is so frowned upon.
Because if the word
is spelt with an H,
you have to pronounce
the H. That's
getting it wrong way around.
Because speech comes
way before writing.
And there's no reason why speech
should be based upon writing.
But in a literate
society, it's often
seen as that's the correct--
so it might be
that that's what's
happening is people are sort
of going back to the spelling
and then producing
a new pronunciation.
Because they're trying to
closely represent what's there.
No, I can't do
anything about it.
[LAUGHTER]
I should just add that.
SPEAKER: I'll take two
more questions, quickly.
AUDIENCE: In the
beginning of your book,
you show how the language
changed over, I think,
the past four, five, six years.
And some words are totally--
you can't understand them, and
you write in current English
how it is.
I know you don't have a crystal
ball, but what do you think--
how many 100 years
will take for people
in the future looking
back how we speak today--
that that will be totally
understandable like
in the beginning of your book?
SIMON HOROBIN: Yeah.
You know, that's an
interesting question.
Because it's certainly true that
if you go back to Old English,
the earliest recorded
form of English,
which is going back
to seventh century,
is that some of the
earliest written records--
but anything between then
and about the year 1000.
The language that-- how it
looked at that point cannot be
understood by a modern English
speaker without the aid
of special study
and a dictionary.
So the language has
changed that radically.
But in fact, if you go to the
period from, say, about 1500--
so if you've ever read the
works of Chaucer, for instance,
that's much closer
to modern English.
And probably looking
up a few words,
you could make some sense of it.
So I think that there was a
particularly radical change
that happened around
about the year 1000
to English, which has meant
that it's now completely
unrecognizable to us.
And part of the
reason for that is
to do with the Norman
Conquest, which--
the influx of French
speakers and so on.
So the language
has changed less.
It's sort of slowed down.
So I don't think
it's going to be
quite as radical in the future.
But the other factor
is, of course,
standardization, which is
an artificial process that
stops the language changing.
It's a break, as it were.
Naturally, English would
change much more in speech.
But of course, we
often say to children
when they're learning the
language, no, no, it's
not foots.
It's feet.
You know, we've artificially
constrained that.
You'd naturally produce
that form first,
but we tell them it's incorrect.
And that slowed it down and made
the changes much less radical.
So that partly is
an answer to say,
I don't think it will
change as radically as
if we look back 1,000 years.
The other thing is, though,
that technology is what's
driving language change today.
And you know better
than I do what
the future is for technology.
In the 15th century,
the printing press
was introduced, which
slowed everything
down and standardized-- made
standardization possible.
Now, you could say
that technology
is driving a destandardization,
promoting variation
so that, in fact--
that could sort of mean
that standard English will
start to be threatened
and language will change
much more obviously.
AUDIENCE: Your talk
was so interesting.
Thank you.
I'm just wondering, OK,
clearly you're telling us to be
a little bit more relaxed-- or
me to be more relaxed than I
have been--
SIMON HOROBIN: It
wasn't you, personally--
AUDIENCE: Apostrophes--
SIMON HOROBIN: If you
felt it was for you--
AUDIENCE: --spelling
and things like that.
But at what point
do you think we
do need to be worried
about sort of descending
into kind of "1984,"
a doublespeak world
where we no longer--
we lose the concept
of what is true,
because language becomes so--
completely kind of falsified?
It's the Ivanka Trump complicit
means blah, blah, blah.
At what point do your sort
of alarm bells go off?
And do you think,
actually, we do
need to object to
this because we are
at risk of sliding into "1984"?
SIMON HOROBIN: I think in
terms of the idea that--
it's often said that's
all fine, but what
about when we cease to be able
to communicate with each other?
When things have gone
down to that stage?
But of course
language is primarily
a system of
communication, so it has
its own methods of
controlling that and stopping
that happening.
So when you know confusion
genuinely sets in,
then there are ways in which
language will self-regulate.
So I don't think it needs that
kind of external regulation
to stop it, because
the speakers themselves
tend to work that out--
so where there is like two
words that really conflict
with each other, what happens
is one usually falls out of use
or becomes very specialized.
So in that sense, I don't think
we need to interfere with it.
But having said
that, there's also
the fact that, for instance,
with me, when my students turn
in essays, I'm still obliged
to tell them, this is right;
this is wrong.
And it certainly would be a
dereliction of duty to say,
don't worry about it.
Don't get so hung up
on apostrophes, guys.
[LAUGHTER]
Because ultimately,
they're going out
into the world of work where
they will be judged on that.
That is right or wrong.
People do judge you
in your language use.
That's just the
way of the world.
So in that sense, those
two things are in conflict,
I would say.
And as long as there
are dictionaries
producing authoritative
statements about correct usage,
I think that helps, in a
sense-- but I mean, that bigger
question about
redefining words--
and that's a very
live one, I think.
SPEAKER: Thank you
very much, Simon.
That was very fascinating
and great fun.
[APPLAUSE]